este año millones de personas han salido
a la calle a celebrar este día del
orgullo gay para que se hagan una idea
según los organizadores se espera que
asistan tantas personas como en el 2019
antes de coronavirus eso fueron 5
millones de asistentes aquí podéis ver
una parte de ellos el desfile ha
comenzado a media mañana son miles de
personas las que participan había muchas
ganas sobre todo después de dos años de
restricciones por la pandemia iba a ser
un desfile también marcado por esa
decisión histórica del tribunal supremo
sobre las limitaciones del aborto aquí
muchos temen que se sigan limitando
derechos como por ejemplo el matrimonio
entre personas del mismo sexo
53 años de celebraciones desde esa
primera marcha aquí en esta ciudad de
1969 a las puertas del bar stonewall
vemos cómo desfilan orgullosos en este
día también hay que celebrar algo
importante y es que el presidente yo
bailé han aprobado una ley en contra de
las terapias de conversión son terapias
para que las personas homosexuales
renuncian a su sexualidad